There's some other terms related to architecture that I"d like to mention for
a minute just so that if we come across them later, you'll know what I was
intending. The first one is conceptual architecture. Obviously, the word
conceptual connotes that it's vague or high level. The reason is fake or
high level is that it's often produced very early in the development process,
in fact before you may even have a complete idea of what the requirements are.
Conceptual architectures are often produces a way to begin the planning process.
Okay, by having an idea of what at a very high level the components and
connectors are going to be, you can begin to block out what the teams might look
like and how long it's going to take to produce the ultimate program. A pair of
other terms to be aware of is the As-Intended versus the As-Built architecture.
During the planning process, the architectural planning process in
which the architectural team decides on what the architecture is going to be and
produces some documentation for
that, the result is the As-Intended architecture. However, during the course of
actual construction of the program, something else may be built, and
we'll call that the As-Built architecture. There are several reasons why
the As-Built may not match ideally with the As-Intended. It may be the case, for
example, that during the course of refinement, the development team
comes across a available component, whether it's open source or
from another group, that can short cut the development process by
providing some needed functionality. But that additional piece may not match
identically with what was intended in the architectural plan.
This process by which the As-Intended becomes the As-Built is sometimes called
architectural drift. And if it happens during software maintenance, that is,
after the program is released and the maintenance team then is dealing with bugs
and enhancement suggestions, the term is sometimes called architectural erosion.
This may arise because the maintenance team, under time pressure to
get the fixes out to the customers, may not make the ideal fix that
would be done if, if the original development were done in a way that was aware
of this particular problem or enhancement. and, perhaps also didn't go back and
make the appropriate changes to the architectural documentation.